no one's here the second we go live we
should have like a million people show
up more than 600,000 packed the room
more than a subscriber base what's going
on here if all of our subs brought five
friends and they brought five friends
five and then they sold those vitamins
yeah we're gonna have so much going on
who's the first person here I see one up
boat who's the first person here oh
three up votes what is up I okay once we
hit the 50 mark we're past the 50 first
50 people to come in hey everyone
hi Marlena Sebastian demo Vader nice
name
Vader Marlena i7 next-door neighbor
named Marlena my dad would go barf Lena
barf leaner and then one day when I was
six years old I told Marlena that and
that did not go over well I thought it
would be really funny oh it wasn't dad
trouble oh yeah he was like why would
you do that I'm like it was funny and
you never specified to me not to say
that Jesus Christ paint nice hair who we
talked to session are you talking to all
right here so here's how we wanted to
hear so I want to do this live stream
okay hey Kenneth hey don't so here's our
wanna do this live stream you guys just
bring up moving news topics and we'll
talk about it all right
I know some people come a little bit
more prepared than us hey Carter Lovejoy
just turned 19 Carter Lovejoy happy
birthday to you I think it's in public
domain no it's not that's a whole thing
don't worry five bucks that he's super
shadow will compensate us for getting
this demonetized anyway there's got to
be a more efficient way to check the
first first movie news thing we noticed
talk about Ward ah ah dude for docs to
talk topical day actually well you know
what's something that I think kind of
transitions it
oh wait no let's talk about that Aladdin
live-action sequel in consideration oh
good the return of Jafar can finally
come here's a live action
well I think what do you think that
would be cool did you see the return of
Jafar no I just saw the commercial on
the VHS tapes how many of you guys saw a
return of the Jafar cuz I actually
really liked that movie a lot
I thought returned Jafar was great but I
don't think they have to follow in the
footsteps of return of Jafar hey Kurt
Andersen you don't want us to shout you
out even though you have to shout out
pledge I'm sorry for doing that sorry
for acknowledging so yeah the return of
Jafar is great but I don't think they
have to follow in the foot so to return
to far a big reason why I wouldn't get
excited about that Jafar guy returning I
think you kind of just like especially
as a version of Jafar wouldn't be as
exciting you got to go completely
different route I I liked his
performance but I wouldn't be excited to
have him come back as like an even
crazier version yeah just wouldn't hike
me up that's that's the issue with it
and now I'm sitting here going are they
gonna keep the whole Jasmine thing or
are they gonna can that I probably
return Ganges Soros thanks so much
thanks so much you know it's more
comfortable to do these live streams on
the phone at the same time though it's
like you missed so many messages that
just keep coming in here ELISA I'm gonna
get the computer message jump pull it up
on the computer and I'll keep everyone
busy right now okay oh they're talking
about that that movie that everyone's
talking about the hunt oh yeah I'm so
excited coming out God October right
it's right around the corner did you
guys buy your tickets come on I'm
excited to check it out oh man great
Betty Gilpin the guy who wrote lost it's
gonna be awesome
what it's been cancelled what knows the
only movie I want to see oh how do you
guys feel about this how do you guys
feel about the hunt being can I
personally I feel like it shouldn't have
been canned I feel like you should have
been postponed
if worst case scenario and there's a lot
of talk going around about censorship
and what this does to films and how so I
heard someone bring up a really
good point about how if you uh if that
movie came out there would be a lot of
talk around the movie and the problems
the movie has but they wouldn't be on
are you listening I'm trying to talk to
you like you're not listening I get
self-conscious Jesus Christ problems the
movie has you know people would focus on
the movie and no one's really focused on
the real issues you know what I mean
like there's real issues out there real
issues and then I don't like how they
try to well point to the movies and then
point to the videogames that arguments
being brought this is the [ __ ] where
I'm like if you wanna argue that the gun
doesn't kill people and you're not
willing to scale back on the
accessibility of those then you can't
also argue the video games and movies
kill people and just jump in and be like
we gotta snatch them up yeah because
there's already people going after video
games too what's funny is like this the
idea of this movie The Hunt has been
compared to the purge and you know I J
okay I really has a version of that idea
inside of it yeah but when it's but when
they have like rich white conservatives
doing it for some reason it's like more
acceptable in the media because we could
better people expect it or something but
yeah and then liberals I don't know it's
all this political statement but I
really ii mean i I think it's more
delicate issue than something like the
interview per se but I also think that
if we were to watch this movie we would
be like yeah not because like it's so
great it shouldn't have been cam but I'm
sure it's not as big of a deal probably
only a nifty violent thriller with a
couple relevant ideas yes mind but not
more so than executing thrills you know
yeah like I think that they should have
you know they should have pushed it like
that they did with death wish mm defa
which is great too under regular Eli
Roth oh yeah you know what I mean that's
let's talk to your Roth
so yeah yeah that's what I get out here
that's what I'd get out here alright so
we got the hunt out of the way Kurt I
won't shut you out thanks who's
everyone's talking about hair it's gotta
be you it's gotta be you
you have the shine might has this shine
today the shine at least from where I'm
standing I'm not salute I guess all
these people subscribed or here when our
hair slicked back so they're like what
the hell is hair's curly whoa did you
change your hair Oh Carter team America
did not get away from political [ __ ]
at all like at all yeah that was a
whipping post for a while yes okay
obviously for how like insanely
offensive that movie tried to be oh we
got a super chat here from saucy to five
three I'm sure that's sauce sees real
profile photo so that's really early
because she's saucy yeah girls like that
watch our channel all the time it's the
way it works you know if he's look at us
we're the sex appeal we appeal to the
sex and sex comes to us that's the way
it goes they actually broadcast our
videos at Paris Fashion Week okay Lana
hi Lana
how you doing dear she said that is her
sure well you guys do reactions to the
boys are you guys already watching
here's what I can tell you we have been
hit with so many yellow dollar bill
signings lately and to do those cut
downs for like when we do on patreon the
cut downs for those things those take
time especially an hour-long show those
let's take a few hours and then the idea
is like we think about like okay what's
like the minimum wage that people
there's ways to factor this out like the
minimum wage you get paid to edit
something hourly and then this is this
worth the time are we making this money
back over the time that we're investing
into it
the boys a Amazon's very strict I'm
surprised some people have gone and
aware of them we've gotten copyright
strikes from Amazon B we're gonna get
yellow dollar bill signs undoubtably all
that if we were to put it up and I
already started watching it for
breakfast I start watching cuz of all
these reasons we were all like there's
no way we can get away with putting this
especially the big moments in the shadow
wanna see yeah oh gosh it's far
straighting like our Game of Thrones
videos and stranger things it's like
those are a lot of a lot of editing time
we hired at
for that and it's like we don't make
that money back and it's about it's not
just if all we ever care about is like
if we hire an editor just to break even
that's the only way oh we were very
clear about that we just want to break
even
yeah and it's a struggle to break even
it's like is this worth it yeah I'll say
the boys is awesome I'm sorry Lana maybe
down the road we have time the idea is
to grow our patreon where we can just
have a full time third editor and the
boys is something I think would be cool
for like maybe John to cover with a
guest download rubs do that because I
don't watch anything now that just in
case I watch a lot of that I'm on
episode 5 my girlfriend I got to that
last night Olivia she's not watching
she's working she loves live streaming
but no well I think I think the boys is
I thought I was just gonna be like pulpy
silly like heart are pretty much like
you know Deadpool kind of territory
except not as you know not breaking the
fourth wall or anything then come to
find out that the show's a lot more deep
it's it's way more insightful has a lot
more serious moments than I expected I
actually don't even when I watch the
show I'm so pulled into the drama and
the intensity and sure there are some
moments are definitely like play for
comedic isn't crazy
yes moment but for the most part I was
I'm pretty impressed with how much it
has on its mind and how much it has to
say I really liked it yeah freaking um I
I can't wait to finish it I think it's a
really compelling show it pretty much
succeeds in doing what the Watchmen
movie and BVS wanted to do in just a
much better way on tops in terms of
breaking I think you really like it it's
a great show I like it's a great [ __ ]
it's not gonna not just like silly
violent fun like for the most part it's
a pretty thoughtful show that's the
biggest surprise I have heard about it
and from just all the responses yeah we
got one from Carter Michael be uncle B's
here fiver from Carter love Joyce's you
guys two dresses Jay and Silent Bob for
Halloween John's got Jays hair had to
say it the thing is I would have a hat
on it looks so much more like salable
whatever what I wanted to say
what I love about this it's Carter's
birthday and he's super chatting us we
should be super chatting you thanks
Carter
I wish it was your birthday every day
dude we would be so much more better off
yeah that would be one time water was
one year I find those photos are
somewhere in the cloud one year he was
seth rogen from pineapple express and I
was James Franco and we looked a lot
like like I got the right wig and
everything so yeah yeah and then another
year we did Sin City you straightened
your hair and you were Dwight and then I
did Marv cuz I was chubby R at the time
uh yes Christopher Padgett and weren't
you at our can you do a what is it Oh
the Dolomites my name is dolomite
trailer ah sorry we watched it without
recording or itself I'm not sure how
much traction it would get I was also a
lot about the music you know how like
Tyrone now Tyrone Magnus will take down
videos now that just get includes
copyrighted content or not monetize you
just takes them down we have to do like
a thing where we just try to see if it's
worth because we do a lot of do you see
these are the videos that are not like
get this up right the [ __ ] now you know
those videos like mmm like a Marvel
trailer we don't really edit those
obviously but for ones that I'm like
okay this is what blader wait let's edit
this we really have to factor in like
well if there's music in it and all that
it's not gonna be it's not gonna be a
big one we kind of want to do it yes so
it's you got a like way those options in
and that was one of those where I was
like okay yeah this is definitely gonna
be yeah the scooter has the potential
get blocked it I'm not one where the
view count will outweigh the potential
money yeah I feel like when you when you
breathe but literally
we're keeping it real with you it was
just about breaking even I'm kidding all
youtubers and influencers are filthy
rich all of them are as wealthy as you
think that we're recording this era they
all made it way too much money
seriously we're everyone's overpaid and
needs to stop complaining this room is
actually huge we just used crazy lenses
to make it look small Oh Britney laying
here and said just one Christopher
Padgett I'm sorry about that I just
wanted to say hi to the both of you
thanks Britney oh you're looking fine
now what was your what was how was
comic-con and what was your part of the
weekend of what was your part is your
part Oh
comic-con was cool I got I didn't talk
to you guys at all about comic there's
my first comic-con hosted the panel and
that was great what John what'd you
think of the panel I thought it was
really fun I mean it would have been
nice if Comic Con had been a little more
organized to have a better attendant but
it was a lot of fun the cast was really
sharp some people got pretty dict over
because there was this whole thing with
a raffle that you had to go at like 9:00
in the morning at the hoarding grant
theater to get your ticket for our thing
instead of just presenting your
comic-con past so there's a lot of
people who got turned away because they
didn't get there - it was weird and the
cast enough I was with the cast that'd
be like man they spend away a lot of
people yeah cuz we were like overbooked
yeah one and two I mean there were some
lines where they really needed that
raffle and this was not a panel where
they did and so I think a lot of people
got turned away just because they didn't
want to go back through the process yeah
so the panel itself was really fun and
we have footage which may appear
somewhere uh yeah well they said that
they recorded the whole thing and they
want to put it online so I'll be sharing
that when it isn't but the panel was a
total blast I was I was a nervous wreck
before doing it ain't almost any new
thing especially something like this I
was like first Comic Con panel I got to
do a great job there really cared about
cast really held you up so yeah I got it
no it's a lot of work you got to like
hang out with the cast beforehand and
really just create a rapport with
everyone so that way when you're making
fun of them they know your dude you
don't [ __ ] mean it yeah
because I want because the idea like we
sat down with the one of the producer
producer writer active part of the show
and I had to we spent like two and a
half hours just mapping out like we
don't want to make this just some boring
Q&A panel let's let's let's make this
like something where people are
entertained the whole time when they're
watching it so that was a total blast
and then so what happened well we got
some few super Jessica Michael shout
stout to Michael B before you get lost
in there so then there was um what what
how do we call it and then we didn't I
didn't have press passes we didn't gonna
do anything like the crazy cool stuff
like Marvel or whatever oh it was cool
just going around we got to meet a whole
bunch of people it's great and I went to
the aro panel and I cried a lot that
really got me emotional not even fully
caught up I'm like a season and a half
behind but I cried yeah it was
definitely an emotional time but I don't
had a great time John no it was a blast
man it was like a crazy adventure
because you know we were always in
motion kind of so some of it was like
okay we're hustling for working ok got a
couple minutes to go have an adventure
and see what I can find and so like this
is kind of an intense weekend but it was
like fun in a weird sort of frantic yeah
yeah yeah and it was John likes having
your support in the crowd and recording
Brandon Alvarado ooh the home alone
reboot Bernadino I put up a video on
patreon like a year and a half ago that
was my full pitch for how I would reboot
home alone I'm gonna give ok Bert Bert
Bernardino Alvarado here's what we
here's what it would be it would be a
twelve part miniseries and it would be
like a slow-moving drama think like mine
hunter something or like true detective
and it just really builds it's yeah it's
like you wouldn't you would just tease
like the Joe Pesci and the other guy
would just tease them like at the end of
every episode but you wouldn't really
spent our them to like episode six but
the whole episode is your walk like
you're watching first episode he's
abandoned at the very end and I would
deal with this as Kevin McCallister is
actually suffering from psychological
abandonment because when I watch home
alone I don't feel like most people I
feel like that Kevin McCallister kid
goes into hardcore denial and then so he
said instead of just realizing my
parents abandoned me he goes into denial
and says he made it family disappear
start celebrating at the fact that his
abusive family abandoned him yeah
family's [ __ ] abusive you watched that
first ten minutes it's everyone's
abusive to him almost no like so then
and then he went deals with these like
he terrorizes a pizza delivery man just
for his own amusement and then he takes
all these criminals at the end and he's
like ready to just annihilate them
murder them so I would do that approach
just like you're watching this kid just
a real kid yeah yeah so mine wouldn't
fit on the Disney plush show that's how
they rejected it but they liked the idea
of a home alone reboot so they're going
with it I don't understand tomate you
would do with the TV there's unless
you're gonna do a from dusk till dawn
where you just expand it out really hard
what could you do in the world for a TV
series that theoretically isn't it's not
miniseries is it no you don't be an
ongoing thing
I just realized my favorite my favorite
life live so yet is my favorite live
streams are the ones where it's just
movie news those are probably my
favorite ones to do you guys rings the
topics that we just like riff that's
that's my favorite okay what's the next
John that's a question for year ending
in Sun how come John doesn't get to go
on any shows I've been on the Schmo down
I don't know Greg is a lot better at
being visible on social media I think
that's got something to do with it
and I could probably be more outgoing
there it is
well I I'm I make the intentional effort
to like go on things like I make a lot
of the connections and I really I talk
with people like I really put myself out
there to that point
you know and it might have to it could
factor in because like we didn't
officially partner up until like two
years ago right Cheers
yeah we're fish alike like Greg and John
real rejects until like two years ago so
I was like end of 2017 something really
likes it was like around my birthday of
17 yeah so there were a couple years
there where I was the face and then a
bunch of guests you know what I mean so
that was that prize consistent so maybe
over time like with the Schmo down I
like I was a see like I don't even know
Chris remembers that do you remember
that like they want to meet you they
wanted me to come on I was like I should
bring on John who that guy you've met
three times yeah do you like he wasn't
even supposed to be on goodbye somebody
touch my spaghetti I don't know what
happened with that I got see you dude so
yeah that was just one of the things
that happened and was the same yeah so
we like I I pushed for John to come on
with me and then he did the free-for-all
it wasn't supposed to be in that because
I hey but your buddy wanted to do that
sure yeah so you know I know John's got
put yourself out there I know I'm just
make it happy she's like yeah most of
these things I don't go on from like
people I get recommended through knowing
people and talking and talking and
putting myself out there for us that's
just kind of how it goes
thanks Josh Irish I appreciate it good
networker you you don't be like I love
now I like to get to know people all
right oh hey Brittany Lange had another
one
Brittany landing did you guys watch the
boat the Beverly Hills 90210 rebooting
yeah no no I didn't even watch the
original no I'm just so we're I just
have like scattered images in my mind
like yeah you know like a secret-agent
movie where at the end I'll remember the
whole thing
well hey Brittany I appreciate
everything you've been contributing here
and so everyone the super chat
appreciated the image contributing but I
know not everyone can contribute in a
super chat so let's take another movie
news question Sean oh no one there let's
get one let's get one I know the proper
thing that live skimmers do is only
responded super I know not everyone
could do that so I don't want to I
wanted some people to not feel so let it
out they've announced that or there's a
five nights at Freddy's game coming in
movie coming in 2021
five nights at Freddy's movie think
about it you make it felt like one of
those hardcore Henry style movies where
it's all first-person but you never let
the character leave the room just
pitched it there's so many movies that
take place in one location that if you
found a way you think it should just be
that these are all three acts of the
movie each one's the same exists each
one is a little harder than the last oh
man hey that would be cool good one dude
Thanks alright back to the super chest
John dumb so how did your went into
stuffs reactions says Eric the grinning
guy how do we do reactions how did we
get into doing reactions I think is the
general I stumbled into it myself
what happened was like we were doing
movie reviews weekly and then I started
up a series of no longer to call
straight to-the-point movie reviews but
you know those required watching a movie
editing that it added and then with
reactions I saw Gator Martin do it and I
thought these are silly who actually
will people actually watch these this is
crazy and then I did one just bring in
my sarcastic self to it and it got a lot
of views I was working a full-time job
then I was like might as well ride the
wave and I just kept doing it made our
own I love you gave me a chance to talk
about a lot of trailers and then also
get into this habit of like it's like I
wasn't actually a big YouTube watcher
and then doing reactions caused me to
like suddenly learn a lot about the
YouTube world and that's how I
discovered on his trailers and stuff so
was from watching all these YouTube
videos and I think what helped us stand
out a lot especially in the beginning
was a lot of people would just react to
YouTube I'll talk about YouTube video
specifically not even like
trailer reaction yeah I'm like there
were so many messages I would get which
I really get these as much now probably
because reactions are just an accepted
medium now but back then like people
would message me going
I don't like reactions and already there
was some people like I don't like the
fact that you did a reaction in my thing
but the fact that you reviewed it and
actually gave insight I'm gonna let you
keep it up so that was cool you know
like people there's the time reaction
she'll just super hated but it was cool
to have like other youtubers so that and
I think that helped me get it like
that's how honest trailers screen
junkies first learned who I was this was
through covering honest trailers and
stuff so all times you just get rekt I
say once you do enough stuff people
start to take notice it was just it was
by accident and it took off took off
what else we got what else we got John
Eric the grounding guys back with
another couple bucks and he says your
channel it's taken over my soul now
thank you thank you thank you Eric the
grounding guy we all forgot Jared what
are your hopes for the Breaking Bad film
that Walter White does not return yeah
yeah yeah the whole movie just takes
place at his view that it doesn't that
even if he does return even in a
flashback that that isn't the highlight
of the movie yeah I don't want to return
me like the best part was when they did
a flashback with Walter why dancing yeah
if you just focused on Jesse or
something like that and and acknowledge
the past with Walt but ya don't jigsaw
him in there to make a kid like he's a
dead full character or something like
that but I'm honestly just weary I'm
just nervous
yeah I don't really have a hopes other
than I hope that this is justified how
well uh yeah I mean I don't know I'm
kind of hesitant I fell off of breaking
some Ruby breaking salt OH breaking
breaking saw better call Saul better
call but Breaking Bad is my favorite
drama of all time hands down so I'm
Trevor dishes about it I'm Peppa dishes
the new Eddie Murphy movie thoughts PS
I'm real thanks your name Lana saucy
lonna from Hawaii I mean I am
theoretically I think it's interesting
this it's like a but it's like a biopic
of Revere a more but like Dolomites
style yeah yeah I didn't think it was
like you know I noticed that Netflix led
the description box with a Academy Award
winner Eddie Murphy Eddie Murphy or
nominee yeah no one ever no one ever
says never really points that out about
Eddie Murphy but I think it's a little
bit more appropriate I'm excited more
for the I like it there's a full
ensemble there more than Eddie Murphy
going on does look like a little much
yeah but I feel like if Eddie Murphy
were to come back I think it's through
movies kind of like striking this bit of
balance I'd like him to be more full-on
weird if anything I said I slightly got
sorry to bother you vibes in the
slightest sense
okay the slightest and I don't think
it's gonna ever go that far at all but I
would like it to push boundaries
especially if Eddie Murphy's gonna go on
Netflix you know like I'd want some is
it alright it's alright okay I feel like
it's an art it has to be all rated yeah
yeah like a blaxploitation icon you
probably Wesley Snipes isn't that sambal
sounds more excited to me than just it's
being told the Eddie Murphy movie but
deanne sambal sounds really cool to me
I'm interested in the idea and and
lately I mean I you know I didn't hear
amazing things about shaft but I do
think it's kind of fun that we're having
all these you know 70s blacksploitation
icons back in in the arena for what yes
and and like it's one of those projects
that I see and I raise my eyebrow and I
go I hope this works because this is
just kooky enough to work but I'm always
worried about Eddie Murphy yeah me too
like oh hey Michael B I could be on the
media dude go subscribe to that guy
little Sarah bringing the bow am l gave
her last year back they've been swapping
items from me oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay I know I know it's yeah I was at
the panel
there's a little girl who always asks a
question apparently at the arrow panels
and and they like swap items and then
she brought back the bow from that
Stephen Amell gave her and it was super
sweet I wasn't a hundred percent sure
what was going on because I had never
seen any of the arrows I cried at other
stuff that made me cry because you were
like wow this Stephen Amell guy makes
such such connect like such a personal
connection with his fans like I could
not believe how I've read like word that
he can be a little standoffish but then
I see the way he connects with fans and
he seems so sensitive to them and I
thought that was just beautiful like
yeah that the whole panel was pretty
much about prey Stephen Amell
none of the arrow verse would exist
without Stephen Amell and it didn't hit
me until that panel that oh yeah like
the whole air overs weren't exist about
this one dear nailing it you know they
call it the air overs yeah it's not like
the DC TV EU or and the fact that it's
ending is sad because it is the origin
of so many things
all right guys we're gonna wrap this up
in a minute or two I got I got some
personal stuff - ten - wanna chime in
Joaquin we're leaving the channels dead
were gone SIA shut it down goodbye
Joaquin I know you just came in but hey
were this is announcements channels done
even Jeanne Jeter even Jeanne Jeter one
of our top hey we saw your short film we
liked it so we're going up this week oh
it's fan of a gene joy matter what yeah
you know we're gonna call this mm-hmm
put out and put out more I think that's
what gene thinks is that I was saying I
did it with people that screen junkies
in Collider movie talk and I see all the
other stuff that we've been on alright
guys thank you so much for being here
like that means a lot to everyone it
takes time to because we never make like
a premiere with our live streams we
don't really make announcements that
we're gonna do it they're usually
spontaneous so thank you to everyone who
contributed to the super chat they never
want to just been here and then
contribute all to this talk literally
our favorite kind of live shows to do
are these random spontaneous ones so
really appreciate it hopefully this
video process is fast enough so it could
just go up on YouTube with you guys much
love to everyone and got Amy Castle
coming back on the channel tomorrow yeah
it's been a long time I'll see you guys
thank you again
much love and